>>> SO I REALLY WANT YOU TO
SETTLE IN FOR THIS ONE.
OKAY?
ARE YOU WATCHING?
A FAMILY WHOSE STORY I'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING FROM THE START OF THE
WAR.
AND I GOT TO MEET THEM ALL
TODAY.
REUNITED AFTER SURVIVING WHAT
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN THROUGH IT
HAS CALLED HELL ON EARTH.
SO LET ME EXPLAIN THIS.
YOU MAY BE REMEMBER JOE RAMERS.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK HE'S ALL THE
WAY ON THE LEFT.
HE'S AN AMERICAN IN UKRAINE
THERE WITH HIS WIFE DASHA WHO IS
UKRAINIAN.
THEY FIRST CAME ON THIS SHOW TO
TALK ABOUT THEIR OWN ESCAPE FROM
KYIV WHEN PUTIN'S INVASION
BEGAN.
BUT DASHA'S FAMILY HAD BEEN
TRAPPED IN MARIUPOL, WHERE
RUSSIA HAS UNLEASHED ITS MOST
BRUTAL AND INDISCRIMINATE
ATTACKS.
SO NEXT TO DASHA THAT IS HER
FATHER, OLEG.
HE WAS TAKING CARE OF HOSPICE
PATIENTS AND DIDN'T WANT TO
LEAVE THEM BEHIND.
AND ON THE FAR RIGHT IS DASHA'S
UNCLE, GENNADY, A PASTOR OF A
CHURCH IN MARIUPOL FULL OF
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED HIM.
FOR WEEKS JOE AND DASHA HAD BEEN
LIVING IN AGONY WITH OLEG AND
DASHA'S MOTHER AND GENNADY, ALL
LIVING IN HELL.
BUT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE
MARCH YUP OL WHICH THEY STILL
CALL THE BEST CITY IN THE WORLD.
TO THEM IT WAS.
TO PUTIN IT WAS A TARGET.
AND IF MARIUPOL IS HELL YOU CAN
GUESS WHO THEY THINK IS DOING
THE DEVIL'S WORK THERE.
THEY FINALLY HAD TO LEAVE OR
RISK FALLING INTO THE LISTEN VE
CAREFULLY TO WHAT THEY WENT
THROUGH AND HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
THIS WAR.
AT TIMES THEY SEEMED
SHELL-SHOCKED.
AT TIMES THEY SEEMED OKAY.
BUT TONIGHT AT LEAST THIS ONE
FAMILY IN UKRAINE IS TOGETHER
ALIVE AND SAFE.
>> SO YOU'RE WAITING FOR THREE
WEEKS FOR THEM TO COME.
>> YEAH.
AND WE KNEW THAT EVERY DAY THE
SITUATION IS GETTING WORSE IN
THE CITY FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTOOD
FROM THE NEWS.
SO YEAH, THAT PART WAS HARD.
>> ARE YOU WATCHING THE NEWS AND
THE PICTURES OF MARIUPOL AND
THINKING -- WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING?
>> I WAS -- WE WERE WATCHING
EVERYTHING, EVERY CHANNEL WE
COULD FIND.
EVERY PAGE ON INSTAGRAM.
WHAT I WAS THINKING, I DON'T
KNOW, SOMETIMES YOU HAVE HOPE.
SOMETIMES YOU THINK I'LL NEVER
SEE THEM AGAIN.
SO JUST -- YEAH.
MIXED FEELINGS.
>> WHEN YOU WERE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM, WHAT WERE
YOU
>> WE WERE TRYING TO MAKE THEM
TRY TO GO OUT OF THE CITY.
MOST OF THE TIME THEY WOULD ASK
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> PART OF THE REASON FOR NOT
GOING I THINK WAS -- AND THEY
CAN ANSWER THIS BETTER.
BUT WAS CONCERN ABOUT IF IT WAS
POSSIBLE TO LEAVE BUT ALSO THEY
FELT RESPONSIBLE TO CARE FOR
BASICALLY BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
CHURCHES WHERE PEOPLE WERE
SHELTERING THERE WERE I THINK
MORE THAN 50 PEOPLE TOTAL, A LOT
OF WHOM WERE ELDERLY WOMEN THEY
WERE CARING FOR.
I KNOW OLEG WAS GOING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN CHURCHES ALMOST
EVERY DAY I THINK THROUGH THE
SHELLING AND EVERYTHING.
>> OLEG, WHY DID YOU STAY?
WHY DIDN'T YOU GET OUT
IMMEDIATELY?
>> Translator: WE WORKED FOR THE
BLUE CROSS MISSION, AND WE TOOK
CARE OF HOSPICE LOCATED
AT THE OUTSKIRTS OF THE CITY.
WHEN THE SHELLING BEGAN THE AREA
WAS HEAVILY AND OFTEN UNDER
FIRE.
SO WE HAD TO MOVE CLOSER TO THE
CENTER.
AND WE WERE TAKING CARE OF
ELDERLY WOMEN.
HOSPICE PATIENTS.
WE MOVED OUR PATIENTS CLOSER TO
THE CENTER.
AND WHEN WE LOST OUR WATER
SUPPLY AND ELECTRICITY IN THE
CITY, WE STARTED AN OPEN FIRE
AND BROUGHT FOOD THERE FOR THESE
PEOPLE.
WE USED A BIG 30-LITER CAULDRON
TO COOK.
AND POWER GENERATORS TO PRODUCE
ELECTRICITY FOR THE OTHER PEOPLE
TO COME CHARGE THEIR MOBILE
PHONES AND DEVICES.
WE WERE PROVIDING FOOD FOR
APPROXIMATELY 40 OR 50 PEOPLE
DAILY.
>> SO YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HE
WORKED FOR THIS MISSION BUT HIS
BROTHER IS A PASTOR OF THE
CHURCH WHERE THEY WERE HIDING.
SO HE CAN MAYBE TELL YOU MORE
ABOUT THIS PART.
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
NOW?
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A LOT ON
YOUR MIND.
>> Translator: I'M TRYING TO
LEARN HOW TO SMILE.
THE PACE OF LIFE THERE IS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
YOU CAN SEE AND FEEL HERE.
IT WAS NOT NORMAL LIFE BUT
SURVIVAL MODE BECAUSE YOU HAD TO
GIVE HOPE TO THOSE WHO WERE
LOSING IT OR WHO WERE SUFFERING
FROM BREAKDOWNS.
AND EVEN THOUGH IT WAS HARD FOR
YOURSELF TO BE IN THESE
CONDITIONS AND AS THE PASTOR OF
A CHURCH IT WAS NOT POSSIBLE TO
GIVE UP AND I NEEDED TO TRY TO
HOLD IT ALL TOGETHER, IT HAS
CHANGED ME FOREVER.
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT HOW THE
ONLY HOPE IS IN GOD.
AND AS WE WERE IN THIS
SITUATION, OUR ONLY HOPE WAS
GOD.
>> AND NOW?
>> I CONTINUE LIVING LINE THAT.
IT WAS AN INTERNAL CHANGE, A BIG
CHANGE.
I CONTINUE LIVING LIKE THAT.
MY TEACHING IS WHAT I TRULY
BELIEVE NOW.
GOD WAS PROTECTING ME.
>> DID THIS MAKE HIM QUESTION
HIS FAITH AT ALL?
OR DID IT STRENGTHEN HIS FADE?
>> Translator: FAITH JUST
LEVELED UP.
I THOUGHT I HAD FAITH, BUT WHEN
I HAD NOTHING ELSE I JUST
REALIZED IT'S REALLY BIG.
>> DID IT EVER FEEL LIKE
WASN'T REAL?
DID HE EVER THINK HE WAS GOING
TO WAKE UP FROM A NIGHTMARE?
>> WHEN THEY WERE BOMBING US
FROM THE PLANES BECAUSE IT WAS
HARD TO BELIEVE THE BOMBS WERE
FLOATING DOWN SO EASILY, I
WITNESSED HORRIBLE THINGS.
I TOLD MYSELF I SEE IT AND IT'S
REALLY HAPPENING.
>> WHAT WAS THE ULTIMATE
DECISION, DECIDING FACTOR FOR
THEM TO COME?
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
LEAVE.
THEY WANTED TO HELP ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE.
WHY DID THEY ULTIMATELY DECIDE
TO COME, TO LEAVE?
>> Translator: THERE WAS ONE DAY
WHEN I WENT OUT TO CALL MY SON
AND HE SAID LEAVE THE CITY.
AND I JUST COULDN'T DO IT TO MY
WIFE.
I WOULD NEVER FORGIVE MYSELF IF
SOMETHING HAPPENED TO HER.
>> HE'S LOOKING AT HIS BROTHER.
HE'S WORRIED ABOUT HIS BROTHER.
WHAT IS HE THINKING?
>> Translator: WE WERE TOGETHER.
WE SHARED OUR PROBLEMS.
BIG PAST.
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> Translator: NEXT QUESTION.
>> YOU'RE LOOKING AT HIM ALMOST
IN TEARS.
HE'S LOOKING AT HIS BROTHER.
AND I CAN TELL HE'S WORRIED
BECAUSE HE'S STUDYING HIM.
AND HE IS THINKING ABOUT A
MILLION DIFFERENT THINGS AS THIS
IS GOING ON.
>> MM-HMM.
>> Translator: I LEFT ON THE
23rd.
MY HOUSE WAS DESTROYED AND MY
GARAGE AND CAR.
THE CHURCH WE WERE LIVING IN WAS
SHOT BY A TANK AND DESTROYED.
I DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE BECAUSE I
WOULD BE THE LAST PERSON TO
LEAVE THE CHURCH AS A SENIOR
WORKER.
BUT THERE WAS A MOMENT WHEN A
CHILD CENTER DIRECTOR CAME TO
ME.
HE'S A MAN OF BIG FAITH.
AND HE TOLD ME, LEAVE MARIUPOL
FOR A MONTH OR TWO BECAUSE YOU
WILL BE PUT IN A CELL BECAUSE
EVERYONE KNOWS YOUR
PRO-UKRAINIAN POSITION.
>> DO YOU FEEL GUILTY ABOUT
LEAVING?
>> A LITTLE BIT.
FOR THE MEMBERS OF MY CHURCH
THAT I COULD HAVE TAKEN ON FOOT,
BUT WE WERE UNDER FIRE.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO GO BACK?
>> THE LONGER I STAY HERE THE
LESS LIKELY.
HOW CAN I LIVE WITH PEOPLE WITH
A DIFFERENT UNDERSTANDING?
>> DO YOU WANT TO GO BACK?
>> Translator: I WOULD LOVE TO
RETURN TO MARIUPOL WHEN IT IS
UNDER UKRAINIAN CONTROL.
I WOULD HAPPILY COME TO REBUILD
THE CITY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
RUSSIANS AND PUTIN?
>> Translator: BIDEN WAS ASKED
ABOUT PUTIN AND CALLED HIM A
BUTCHER.
I AGREE WITH HIM.
>> Translator: PUTIN DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE IS JUST A TOOL IN THE HANDS
OF THE DEVIL.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM?
WHAT DO YOU WANT HIM TO KNOW?
>> Translator: I WOULD LIKE HIM
TO COME TO MARIUPOL AND SEE HOW
PEOPLE LIVED AND DIED.
I WOULD LOVE HIM TO EXPERIENCE
THAT.
RUSSIANS ARE STARTING TO BELIEVE
IN THEIR OWN PROPAGANDA LIES.
I HAD A HEATED DISCUSSION WITH A
RUSSIAN OFFICER.
HE WAS CONVINCED THAT THEY HAD
COME TO HELP US.
HE SAID HE WOULD FREE US FROM
THE NAZIS.
I LOOKED INTO HIS EYES, AND HE
BELIEVED IT.
I TOLD HIM I WAS RUSSIAN AND
I'VE NEVER SEEN A SINGLE NAZI IN
MARIUPOL.
HE WAS SURPRISED.
>> WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> Translator: THAT HE HAS SEEN
NAZIS AT THAT CHECKPOINT.
THEY CHECKED US FOR TATTOOS.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY CHECKED FOR
NAZIS.
>> HOW MANY CHECKPOINTS?
>> Translator: 12 CHECKPOINTS.
>> AND YOU HAD TO DO IT EVERY
TIME?
>> Translator: IT WAS ONLY
RUSSIAN MILITARY CHECKPOINTS.
THEY SAID THAT THEY WERE
MOBILIZED.
THEY DIDN'T CHOOSE TO GO TO THIS
WAR AND THEY WERE MADE TO DO IT.
AND IT WASN'T THEIR CHOICE.
>> WHAT WAS -- HOW MANY PEOPLE
LEFT WITH THEM?
>> SEVEN PEOPLE WERE IN THE CAR
WITH US.
>> WERE THEY WORRIED THEY
WEREN'T GOING TO MAKE IT?
>> Translator: THREE TIMES WE
WERE UNDER FIRE.
AS WE WERE LEAVING A CHECKPOINT,
SHELLS WERE EXPLODING
EVERYWHERE.
PEOPLE DOVE INTO THE FIELD AND
COVERED THEIR HEADS.
ONE PERSON WAS HIT BY SHRAPNEL
THREE CARS AHEAD.
>> DID THEY HAVE FOOD?
>> Translator: I DIDN'T HAVE
TIME TO GATHER FOOD.
WE ONLY HAD FLATBREADS AND TWO
CANS OF FISH.
THE WHOLE JOURNEY TOOK AROUND
FIVE DAYS.
>> DID YOU FEEL LIKE THIS WAS
HELL?
LIKE IS THIS EVER GOING TO BE
OVER?
WHEN IS THIS GOING TO BE OVER?
>> Translator: IT WAS LIKE A
DIFFERENT REALITY.
TAKEN OUT OF YOUR NORMAL LIFE.
IT WAS NEW.
IT WAS A STATE OF NOT KNOWING
WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> ONCE YOU GOT HERE, ONCE YOU
SAW THEM, WHAT WAS YOUR
REACTION?
>> WE WERE WAITING FOR THEM.
GLAD THEY'RE HERE.
>> I THINK IN ALL OF HUMAN
HISTORY THERE'S NEVER BEEN A GUY
WHO WAS MORE EXCITED TO GET A
CALL THAT HIS IN-LAWS WERE
COMING TO VISIT.
IT DOESN'T REALLY FEEL LIKE THE
CRISIS IS OVER.
WE -- MORE DASHA AND MORE THEM.
BUT WE STILL KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
THERE.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING
FOR THAT REUNION THAT WE GOT WHO
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN IT AND
PROBABLY WON'T EVER GET IT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BE OKAY?
YEAH?
>> YEAH.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BE OKAY?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE OKAY?
HOW DO YOU WANT THIS TO END?
>> Translator: WHAT EXACTLY?
>> THE WAR.
>> Translator: THE WAR?
>> HOW DO YOU WANT THIS TO END